[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello I'm Sachin Gupta vpgm for
infrastructure at Google Cloud
the roles of Enterprise Architects and
developers are evolving
not only do you have to keep the lights
on you are expected to stay on top of
the ever-changing trends and
technologies that create business value
and you have to do all of this while
lowering costs and improving performance
so it infrastructure runs quickly and
smoothly
Your Role is critical to a successful
transformation
for example adopting Technologies like
AIML and containers is becoming vital to
businesses with more than 76 percent of
surveyed Enterprises saying that AI
projects are their top priority
and meanwhile security breaches are so
common these days it doesn't even make
the top news
they are disruptive and costly and can
be avoided with the right preventative
methods after all as Gardner says 99 of
cloud breaches are due to human error
with Google Cloud you can innovate
faster and more easily while optimizing
costs
we know organizations like yours still
have a lot of infrastructure to migrate
and we are committed to helping you
migrate more securely and efficiently
Global customers and local Partners like
Palo Alto Networks h m and Major League
Baseball rely on us to deliver scalable
High performing highly available Cloud
infrastructure and services
a big area we're investing in is the
expansion of our Global footprint to
meet the unprecedented Global customer
demand
today I'll be discussing how we are
partnering with you to help Drive
business value in three key ways
first we are driving business
transformation and achieving new
outcomes with industry-leading AIML
unparalleled security and modern
infrastructure services and solutions
that are designed for your industry
second
we're helping you optimize your workload
performance while reducing costs
and finally from migration to management
our mission is to help you unlock this
value simply and easily
customers come to Google Cloud to
transform
and innovate
let me share a little more about how we
are driving this change through AI
leadership invisible security and
Cutting Edge industry Solutions AI is in
our DNA
from AI powered search to YouTube
recommendation engines and Google
Assistant
we have Decades of experience running
scaled diverse ML workloads and
industry-leading AI infrastructure
products and solutions Wayfair is using
vertex AI to forecast Global customer
demand ensuring customers can quickly
access what they need
and to automate and personalize AI
powered customer support
Salesforce is using performance
optimized Cloud TPU V4 for
conversational scale out AI these
outcomes are made possible because of
the Innovation across our AI stack
and it starts with Hardware choices and
performance that help you keep pushing
the limits of AI in large models
Cloud TPU V4 delivers industry leading
ml training performance and scale with
six terabits per second interconnect you
can run large-scale training workloads
up to 80 faster and up to 50 percent
cheaper compared to alternatives
and that's how companies like cohere
deliver cutting-edge natural language
processing faster and with a lower
carbon footprint
we're also announcing new A2 Ultra gpus
built on nvidia's A180 gig gpus with
high-speed memory
AI Singapore has reduced the loading
time of large-scale language models by
40 percent
and increased throughput by over 50
percent with A2 plus resulting in
increased productivity
and customers are also using Google
batch to orchestrate and schedule AI
jobs of any scale
with batch our customer locomotion was
able to unlock AI insights from their
autonomous trucks 80 faster
Google is committed to making Ai and
machine learning more open and
accessible
to further this in partnership with meta
we recently co-founded the pi torch
Foundation
and for over a decade we've contributed
to critical AI projects like tensorflow
and Jacks
today we are announcing a new industry
Consortium the open xla project that
will unite an ecosystem of leading
machine learning compiler Technologies
and accelerate and simplify machine
learning innovation
these open source AI contributions
enable you to take your AI idea and turn
it into reality easily and at low cost
next I want to share how we're
transforming security
at Google Cloud we are championing a
future of invisible security where
security is engineered in and operations
are simplified
we package the expertise that we use to
protect our own business and our
billions of users and make it available
to you
you can easily deploy a wide range of
tools depending on your own risk profile
from prevention to detection to
remediation
today I want to highlight the next step
in our cyber security Journey as we
welcome mandiant to Google Cloud
by taking advantage of Google Cloud's
existing security portfolio our Google
cyber security action team and mandian's
leading cyber threat intelligence you
can stay protected at every stage of the
security lifecycle
Cloud armor is another security
innovation that provides Advanced ml
power DDOS and Waf protection for web
apps services and apis
it has prevented some of the largest
DDOS attacks on the planet with zero
impact to customers
recently the largest https attack was
staged against a cloud armor customer
it was 76 percent larger than anything
previously reported the equivalent of
Wikipedia's daily requests in 10 seconds
and the customer experience no impact
and for regulated Industries with
stringent and Country specific
requirements we offer controls to meet
your digital sovereignty objectives
Sovereign controls allows you to define
the location of your core data set
access permissions and control your
cryptographic keys
supervised Cloud which is coming soon is
a fully partner managed and operated
solution that supports data operational
sovereignty needs and Country or
region-specific regulatory requirements
for highly sensitive workloads that
require the most stringent security
requirements hosted Cloud offers
air-gapped hardware and software
including managed infrastructure AIML
and database services
since transformation takes different
forms for different Industries we
partner with customers to build
industry-leading innovative solutions
together with the CME Group we plan to
transform the derivatives Market through
technology expanding access and creating
efficiencies for Market participants
in Telecom Communication service
providers like Bell Canada rely on
Google's Network to expand globally and
deploy 5G networks with Google
distributed Cloud Edge
Google distributed Cloud Edge GPU
optimized configurations bring the power
of GPU acceleration and machine learning
to enable the future of retail
customers and partners such as 66
degrees awm smartshelf
and ipsotec are using GPU optimization
to deliver Innovative retail Solutions
at the edge
including AR in the store
shelf stock out notifications for
quicker restocking and cashier checkout
to reduce lines
in media and entertainment we provide
solutions to customers like you next
with streaming built on the same Google
infrastructure we've tested and tuned to
serve YouTube's two billion users
globally
to get a better picture of how our media
and entertainment industry customers
innovate with Google Cloud I'm proud to
introduce senior vice president
technical infrastructure of Major League
Baseball Truman boys
[Music]
he's got it
Major League Baseball's technology
mission is to connect with our fans
our infrastructure team has historically
maintained applications on-prem and now
we have unlimited compute from the
public cloud and this allowed us to shut
down four data centers modernize all of
our infrastructure and to spin things up
rapidly
and in the off season we scale it back
Google's Cloud helps us to understand
the entire fan journey and artificial
intelligence allows us to derive a
better connection to them we're able to
have personalized content with that fan
it gets richer over time as we learn
more about them
working with Google we're preserving the
history of baseball going back into the
1940s and we're able to make highlights
available to our fans Google Cloud hosts
all of these video clips for us
and now we have an opportunity to enrich
this format beyond what it is today
we're looking to modernize the entire
platform that we have and move into
delivery through media CDN
Major League Baseball and Google Cloud
are connecting with our fans so that
experience is happening in venue as well
as a digital experience and we're
knocking it out of the park
thank you so much Truman it is amazing
to see how MLB is innovating for The Fan
Experience leveraging Google
Technologies like AI media CDN and the
reliability and elasticity of our Global
infrastructure
we've shared a number of ways in which
we've built our infrastructure to enable
transformation
but we also continue to build Solutions
and products tuned to support your top
workloads and data applications
and we've optimized these for both
performance and cost
one example of this is Google Cloud
VMware engine
VMware engine is a fully managed native
Google service that helps you lift and
shift your VMware applications to Google
Cloud faster and easier
we are the first external provider to
support vmware's Cloud Universal program
which makes it easier for you to migrate
to the cloud
and with built-in point-and-click
migration tools and our instant
provisioning feature you can get
workloads running in your private cloud
in less than one hour
customers like liq have saved 60 in
infrastructure costs with VMware engine
by migrating 80 percent of their
business applications and half of their
databases
We are continuing to scale VMware engine
by increasing support from 64 to 96
nodes per private Cloud all with four
nines of availability in a single site
and a dedicated 100 gigabit per second
Network
this provides high performance and
reliability for your most demanding
production workloads
it is no wonder that customers like
mitel could overhaul their unified
communications platform and data
infrastructure with VMware engine in
less than 90 days
another example of workload optimization
is a recently announced Google Cloud
high performance Computing toolkit
several decades ago Quantum Computing
was just a concept
but now with HPC toolkit Quantum AI is
easy and accessible
HPC toolkit is an open source tool from
Google that helps you quickly and easily
create repeatable TurnKey HPC clusters
the toolkit comes with several
Blueprints and Broad support for
third-party components such as the slurm
scheduler Intel dials and ddn luster
storage
next I'm really excited to announce C3
VMS
it is the first VM on the market to
feature the latest generation of Intel
Sapphire Rapids processors and it's
built on new Intel Google co-designed
infrastructure processing units or ipus
all of this together means
differentiated performance security
isolation and flexibility
C3 is the first VM in our Fleet with 200
gigabits per second low latency
networking to support a variety of
workloads such as data processing web
serving and high throughput HPC
workloads
because clusters can be scaled and
parallelized more densely we're seeing
customers and partners like ansys and
Snapchat completing jobs faster
and parallel works is seeing 10x faster
performance with C3
compared to the prior generation
contact your sales rep to join our
private preview
moving on to another product built to
Leverage The ipu Google cloud hyperdesk
is the next generation of block storage
which will be available on both compute
engine and gke
we are decoupling block storage
performance from the VM allowing you to
tune your storage performance to your
workload needs
we estimate you'll see around 50 percent
better total cost of ownership than
persistent disk and 80 higher iops per
vcpu compared to any other hyperscaler
we have built cost optimization into
many of our core products and we have
exciting new capabilities to announce
our new flexible committed use discounts
or Flex Cuts can make it easier to save
and manage costs across teams by giving
you region and VM family flexibility
with auto class
customers like redovis are reducing
storage costs and achieving Better Price
predictability in a simple way
it automatically transitions objects to
cooler storage based on the last time
they were accessed and transitions to
standard storage upon access
that brings us to the third way we drive
business value ease of use
as Cloud platforms have become more
versatile they often have also become
more complex to adopt and operate
that's why Google Cloud strives for
radical simplicity
from migration through management
speaking of migration our new migration
Center can reduce complexity time and
cost
by providing key capabilities in
migrating and modernizing to Virtual
machines containers or serverless
computing
with migration Center viant a large
Media company in partnership with slalom
successfully migrated an entire data
center to Google cloud in less than six
months we also have a new offering in
our Mainframe modernization solution
called dual run
dual run lets you replicate your
Mainframe workload in Google cloud and
run the two environments in parallel
this allows you to confirm successful
operations in Google Cloud
before your cutover which can massively
reduce risk
and that's why customers and partners
across Industries like financial
services companies Santander are seeing
success with dual run
we also want to simplify the way you
manage and scale
managed instance groups or migs with
auto scaling use application metrics to
radically simplify and improve
operational efficiency
allowing you to scale in and out without
manual intervention
and with the power of Google's ml mix
can predictably scale in and out based
on historical data
these three defining pillars for Google
Cloud infrastructure
transformative
optimized and easy
are the key tenets behind our
intentional engineering efforts
this is why so many customers trust
Google Cloud
and what helps to power such Innovation
across the industry
I invite you to try Google cloud and our
Innovative new releases we look forward
to delighting you
thank you
[Music]